[Music]
all right I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Rubin report it's October 18th 2023
we're live streaming on Rumble locals
we're on Spotify we're on YouTube as
long as they'll allow us if you haven't
subscribed particularly on Rumble
rumble.com Ruben report and if you want
to join us for the postgame show and get
me some extra questions
find out a little bit more about the
behind the scenes situation and some of
the other things that we are up to and
have uh we've got some big things coming
over the next couple weeks you can join
us at Ruben report. locals.com uh before
we get to the program today I uh had to
cut our postgame show short yesterday
because we did the show when we started
doing this show like me direct to camera
like two years ago our intention was to
do a half hour a day and then it was in
an election year and it kind of moved to
45 minutes a day and now we're like an
hour a day and sometimes going on a
little bit uh longer than that and I
appreciate all all of you for uh our
watch times are like through the roof
like this is not you know YouTube people
watch things for two seconds and jump
away our watch times people are watching
the show for 40 45 minutes sometimes the
full thing it's it's really great uh but
I did have to cut the postgame show a
bit short yesterday because I mentioned
that I was going to get some extra guns
we've got some guns here thought I'd
show you one picture something that I uh
well I'm not going to say whether I
picked it up for myself or not but uh
you can never be too careful in these
trying times that all I'm saying uh yes
we live in a completely Wacky World we
are going to cover some of the wackiness
you guys know that Beyond just sort of
the
nitty-gritty and the horrors of what's
happening and that that there's still
200 hostages and babies and all of that
stuff uh one of the things that I'm
always most interested in is the
narrative right like the media narrative
how the media lies how they confuse you
how they make the good guys seem like
bad guys and bad guys seem like Good
Guys how our politicians lie about
almost everything uh the entire
institutional layer in America has
completely collapsed basically so decent
people are now trying to figure out
something true and they don't know what
television show to watch or what online
show to watch or who to listen to in the
government and when you have chaos of
that order it's no surprise uh that you
have people like what should be good
decent young people out in the streets
basically chanting for genocide so I'm
going to talk about how we kind of got
there and how many of the institutions I
even have a copy of the New York Times
on my desk today which we'll get to in a
moment uh have led us to the precipice
of the the abyss I would say in a lot of
respects uh so that is what we are doing
on the Ruben report program today before
we get to it let me talk to you about
gravity def Fire Shoes guys I want to
tell you about something that's been
making my days as a whole a lot easier
gravity to fire shoes they these shoes
are something else I mean I'm a fan of
comfortable Footwear people have known
that for years but these shoes take it
to a whole new level more than just
shoes there basically clouds for your
feet I'm not joking in a double blind
study by Olive View UCLA Medical Center
and published in the Journal of the
American podiatric Medical Association
participants experienced 85% less knee
pain it's the most powerful shock
absorption system put into a shoe
gravity to fire has the patented Verso
shock technology it's like a mini
trampoline in your shoes whether you're
strolling through the park running
errands or even just lounging at home
these shoes have got your back I use
them when I'm doing cardio I should say
your feet not just your back actually uh
even better they're stylish you get both
comfort and style that look good and
feel great so here's the deal the
gravity to fire people are offering an
exclusive offer to the Ruben report head
on over to
gy.com
gy.com use promo code ruben2 at checkout
and get an extra $20 off your order this
$20 discount is a thank you gift from
Gravity to fire for you being here with
us today why not treat your feet to some
Welles deserved Comfort go to G DFI
y.com use promo code
ruben2 and now back to me all right so
the lying liars and the people who
promote those lying Liars so we've got
AOC coming up we've got CNN and a whole
bunch more New York Times and everything
else but I want to show you first you
know we've played you a couple videos of
AOC in the last couple days not only
what she's saying now which are always
lies they're always in defense of Hamas
she has no idea what she's talking about
in terms of facts on the ground and
history and everything else we showed
you a video a few days ago I think we've
showed it to you twice this week or
maybe once was last week uh of her back
in 2017 being asked the most basic
questions about the history of Israel
and she she simply has no idea what
she's talking about so last night she
went on or yesterday afternoon she went
on CNN and I first off I want to credit
the journalist I it's it's important to
give credit where credit is due the
journalist did a really nice job do do
we know her name we we'll check her name
while we we play the clip because she
really did a nice job of asking AOC
basic basic questions about the history
about America's involvement and AOC just
flounders and stammers through the whole
thing but one I want to show you one
clip of AOC here uh of AOC right here
because she's going after Ron Des santis
because Dan santis has basically said we
should not take any Gins as refugees and
of course we shouldn't first off we
should have a closed border right now we
should figure out who's in this country
and everything else doesn't matter Gaza
or anywhere else no uh there are 20 some
odd Arab Muslim nations you can take the
Palestinians we have no idea what these
people have been taught where their
allegiances are we clearly don't have
the right people working the border to
vet these people properly we have a
whole bunch of problems in our country
like it's just obvious and the santis is
just saying the obvious thing that may
be politically incorrect but we all know
anyway uh the journalist asked AOC about
desantis's retoric on gazen immigration
I want to get you to respond to uh
something that Republican candidate for
president Ronda Santa said about the
potential for refugees from Gaza just
take a
listen and I don't know what Biden's
going to do but we cannot accept people
from Gaza into this country as refugees
I am not going to do that uh if you look
at how they behave not all of them are
Hamas but they are all anti-semitic none
of them believe in Israel's right to
exist there's a lot in there but
I wonder for you does is he touching on
something that uh that is perhaps real
here should Arab countries be taking on
The Lion Share of the burden to absorb
what could be over a million if not more
refugees from Gaza I think there's
something to be said about the Region's
Partners being able to support and step
up Palestinians however that does not
abdicate the United States from our
historic role that we've played in the
world of accepting refugees and allowing
people to restart their lives here and I
also want to address something very
specific about what uh Governor DeSantis
said when he said quote unquote all Gins
are anti-semitic how incredibly
destructive and dangerous that rhetoric
is we just had a six-year-old boy
stabbed 26 times this morning because of
rhetoric like that and it is dangerous
it is unacceptable it is reckless and no
leader in the United States of America
should be amplifying a message like that
can we send her can we jump on someone
get on Amazon get a really nice mirror
and we can can we send it to AOC because
I really need her to look in the mirror
when she thinks her rhetoric or when she
thinks desantis's rhetoric is getting
somebody killed it's just so profoundly
absurd first off G Hamas runs basically
all the schools in Gaza they teach the
kids to hate Jews to hate the West all
of that stuff there is no reason to
think is it is it literally every person
Poss possibly not but at the rallies as
I've been saying at these rallies that
are now happening in New York City and
Chicago and in Boston and London and
Paris and all over the place do you see
anyone making the distinction guys it's
not all the Jews could everybody no
they're literally chanting from The
River To The Sea they're having gas the
Jews all of the phrases right on top of
the fact that we have absolutely zero
duty to take these people in what about
their Arab brothers and sisters they
don't want them that is the truth we
have no duty to do it on top of the fact
that AOC has run out of her way to
apologize for what Hamas has done to uh
well she's not apologizing for it but
she's basically running cover for it
that's a better way to say it she's
running cover for the atrocities that
they've committed she's consistently
lying about everything that Israel is
trying to do and how Hamas is using
human Shields and everything else it is
her who do you think is more if you're
living in America right now who's a
little more concerned about about their
life right right now do you think that
there is like a lot of Palestinian
Americans who are concerned a bunch of
Jews are going to break into their house
and kill them are there a bunch of Jews
having rallies talking about kill all
the Palestinians or kill all the Arabs
or is it the other way it's the other
way when I got guns yesterday the guy at
the gun shop told me that basically
everyone walking into that shop and he
said he's selling now uh I think what he
said was he's selling now more guns that
at any time in the 20 some odd years
that he's had the shop other than right
like basically the first week of coid
and he said basically everyone walking
in here is a Jew so everything she says
is a lie of course it's a lie here's
DeSantis uh completely cleanly clearly
honestly uh saying the truth related to
refugees and the fact that these people
are taught horribly anti-American things
even if you think it's kind of okay well
they hate the Jews but we could still
let them in do you think they care about
Free Speech do you think they care about
the Bill of Rights uh on top of all the
other problems we have and everything
else here is the sanas and it's all just
true it's just true there is an
indoctrination in cartoons
and in books at the youngest ages and
these kids are being taught to hate the
Jews and even kill the Jews uh that
indoctrination is
real exactly so we're no my position is
very clear as the first president TR K
say no Gaza refugees period we're just
not going to do it and why because we
don't want to import the pathologies
from the Gaza Strip and other places in
the Middle East to the United States of
America Amica they are taught to hate
Jews they are taught that Israel has no
right to exist the textbooks that they
use don't even have Israel on the map at
all and so this is just endemic to their
culture it's a really toxic culture
that's developed so there's no reason to
be importing that into the United States
and the idea that we can kind of
separate like a terrorist from some
someone that may be a freedom lover that
just doesn't work uh so so we will not
do that uh when I'm president
you know what he said there at the end
is the important part because as I said
of course there are there are some good
people there and maybe there are some
people who are against Hamas we don't
hear them saying anything and I have I
have sympathy with that because Hamas
would treat them like they would treat
the Israelis right but even if you were
out there saying okay you know we should
take some of these people do you
honestly you person watching this
program right now do you honestly
believe that our system and our Border
Protection people and the people that
would interrogate and ask these people
what they believe do you think we have
the best of the best working in the
government right now and we'd be able to
ascertain what their beliefs are you you
may say okay well sure they all grew up
watching cartoons on how to kill the
Jews and you know Israel's evil and all
that stuff but but certainly they
wouldn't hate America they'd come here
and Love Freedom except we now have uh
they really are riots they haven't
started burning down buildings yet but
it's coming uh we have these protests
now where they're not only just talking
about getting rid of Israel they're
talking about getting rid of America
right because if you don't think that
the Jews are kind of indigenous to the
ancient land of Israel right the
Biblical land of Israel if you think
those things have nothing to do with
each other what do you think they think
about the 250e history of America right
well how do you think we all got here
that's next guys like that absolutely is
next but it's not just AOC and it's not
just the usual suspects that are lying
it's basically the entire media
establishment and much of that was
proven last night
uh on this this bombing of a hospital in
Gaza we will get to that I'm going to
expose a whole bunch of BS which is it
kills me to have a New York Times
sitting on my desk while I'm trying to
tell the truth we're going to get to all
that in just a second let me talk to you
guys about Field of Greens real quick uh
guys I don't want to nagg you about your
diet and I don't always eat healthy
either although I am at my lowest weight
in 20 years believe it or not but I will
share that the Mayo Clinic says if you
want to help prevent heart disease lower
blood pressure and cholesterol eat five
servings of fruits and vegetables every
day you might want to you might might
not be able to and you probably won't so
that's why you should take Field of
Greens unlike the others each fruit and
vegetable and Field of Greens was
medically selected by doctors to support
your vital organs like heart lung
kidneys and immune system blue season
here and I Trust Field of Greens to help
me stay healthy Field of Greens Works
fast you'll feel better with more energy
and you'll notice your skin hair and
nails will look healthier too look at my
nails if you don't always eat right in
exercise join me and take Field of
Greens let me get you started with 15%
off your first order visit field ofg
greens.com use promo code Dave that's
promo code Dave fieldof greens.com
fieldof greens.com and now back to me
all right so we know it's not just AOC
right it's not just the Biden
Administration it's not just the rest of
the Hamas caucus I want to give credit
her name was Abby Phillips by the way
you probably saw her name the girl that
uh interviewed AOC there she really did
a nice job and she exposed her on a
bunch of other stuff as well and you
could see even the way if you watch the
full thing maybe we'll play some more
clips of it tomorrow if you watch the
full interview she talks to AOC in such
a slow manner because she knows AOC is
basically an idiot and she doesn't want
to make it seem like she's partisan so
she's trying to like she like Kid Glove
her with the questions but anyway now I
have to be critical of AOS of uh well I
have to be critical of AOC but I have to
be critical of CNN uh because yesterday
uh it was I think it was in the
afternoon it probably about 5 o'clock
Eastern time here suddenly the media and
Twitter and everything was blowing up
that Israel had bombed a hospital in
Gaza uh of course it has now turned out
to be completely untrue we're going to
show you a bunch of evidence of that uh
but here is Jake Tapper on CNN and I
what do I keep telling you about Jake
the problem with Jake Tapper is he's not
completely brain dead almost everyone on
CNN is completely brain dead or they're
a propagandist or a liar right almost
everybody Jake has this thing where
basically one out of every 10 things he
says is right or true like suddenly the
neurons fire he says something honest
and then everyone's like see Jake Tapper
is not that bad then he lies about nine
more things everyone's like screw Jake
Tapper then he says something fine as
opposed to just like put it out there
like either be horrible or just pick one
pick one you're driving everybody crazy
so here's Jake Tapper uh spewing pure
Hamas propaganda about a a horrifying
Israeli War crime a major story
developing right now in Gaza what the
Palestinian government is calling a war
crime the government in Gaza says the
Israeli Defense Forces struck a hospital
in the center of Gaza City Al Ali
Baptist Hospital preliminary estimates
from the government in Gaza but the
number of killed in the strike somewhere
between two and 300 we expect there are
many more innocent people still trapped
under the rubble that is not journalism
Jake Tapper what you are doing is acting
as the public relations wing for a
terrorist group and he says Palestinian
officials the Palestinian government
he's talking about Hamas so Hamas
something blew up we'll get to that in
just a second something did blow up uh
but Hamas then just releases a statement
and he repeats it as if he's working PR
and actually that's what CNN is MSNBC is
fullon like we're in it with Hamas but
CNN is kind of pretty much there too
that's not journalism and you know it's
not journalism but before we go and and
debunk some of the nonsense the Hamas
caucus ilhan Omar and Rashida TB and a
bunch of others chimed in immediately
they had no evidence that Israel had
done anything here absolutely no
evidence it has now come out completely
inclusively that Israel did not do this
we're even going to show you video in a
moment but listen to Ilan Omar on
Twitter and this tweet is still up right
now bombing a hospital is among the
gravest of war crimes the IDF reportedly
blowing up one of the few places that
injured and wounded can seek medical
treatment and shelter during a war is
horrific pus president of the United
States needs to push for an immediate
ceasefire to end this Slaughter so she
got that tweet out 3:12 p.m. Eastern so
it was right as it happened and all they
did on that was just listen to to what
Hamas said here's Rashida Talib other
member of the Hamas caucus Israel just
bombed the Baptist Hospital killing 500
Palestinians she had no evidence of this
doctors children's patients just like
that pus this is what happens when you
refuse to facilitate a ceasefire and
help deescalate your war and destruction
only approach has opened my eyes and
many Palestinian Americans and Muslim
Americans like me we remember where you
stood she is an enemy combatant in the
United States we have two we have at
least two I would say AOC three there's
probably five others with Bowman members
basically who support Hamas right now in
the United States government so I'll get
to the debunking in just a moment but
now check out the New York Times three
times they changed the headline
on this thing here you go their first
headline when they're just swallowing
the Hamas propaganda hole Israeli strike
uh kills hundreds in hospital
Palestinians say no evidence of it the
Palestinians said it we're a newspaper
all the propaganda that's fit to print
then they changed it a little bit a
little later at least 500 dead in strike
on Gaza Hospital Palestinian St so now
it's not Israeli strike now they
degraded it just to a strike and now
when they found out a little bit more
info uh at least 500 dead in Blast now
it's not a strike because now they
realize it actually wasn't a missile
strike it was a blast uh at Gaza
Hospital uh so before we debunk it I
want to show you something that you have
not seen I know you have not seen it
because we didn't even talk about it
because nobody uh saw this uh but on
October 11th just last week what's that
one week ago today was one week ago
today Hamas actually did bomb a hospital
in Israel uh this is barali Hospital in
ashalon Israel and a rocket directly hit
the
hospital
could we double check did uh did ilhan
Omar tweet about that are we able to
check on that one could we uh did
Rashida to anybody maybe maybe your
Twitter's glitching or uh yeah the fact
that I didn't even know about that until
I saw it yesterday right like think
about that the other interesting thing
about this is and again we're going to
debunk the thing in just a second every
single rocket so they they've fired now
about 7,000 Rockets into Israel every
rocket these are just indiscriminately
lamed Rockets they're just firing all
over every single one is AED at a
civilian right every single one is aimed
at a hospital or a synagogue or whatever
like any sort of Civilian infrastructure
they'd love to kill military people too
but every single one that they do right
and somehow no nothing from the Hamas
caucus uh BB Netanyahu shared this and
then we'll debunk it for you the whole
world should know it was the brutal
terrorists in Gaza who struck the
hospital in Gaza not the IDF whoever
brutally kills our children kills his
own children as well now you don't have
to take BB netanyahu's word for it right
and I shouldn't right no you shouldn't
just take the word of any official
anything in any of this I think there is
there's one side that is a barbaric
medieval genocide cult that is beheading
people we should understand that that's
one side of this and then there's
another side that is a western democracy
that plays by real rules but that
doesn't mean that you should just take
their word for everything but how about
in this case we take the word word from
Al jazer because Al jazer broadcast out
of Qatar it's Qatar owned uh which Qatar
as you know that's where the leadership
of Hamas is uh they broadcast the exact
moment that it was an Islamic Jihad
rocket launched from Gaza and it broke
in in midair because a lot of the
Rockets fell about 450 as of yesterday
have hit Gaza itself so they've fired
four they fired 7,000 Rockets towards
Israel 450 of them have landed in Gaza
and done old Untold destruction there
here's video and there this is Al
freaking jazer they're show the rocket
going blowing up and then the shrapnel
hitting below and it hits the
hospital
yeah that's Al jazer how often am I
playing Al jazer on here to prove
something I mean Al jazer so you can
what you're seeing there is the rocket
go from Gaza right it's going towards
Israel it blows up some of them they're
they're rudimentary Rockets often made
from pipes that Israel helped import
there to bring in water and it blew up
and the shrapnel and everything else the
payload hit uh hit what they're telling
us was a hospital but we have more on
that in just a second here's this was
just released by audio here's audio uh
by Sorry by Israel this is audio of a
conversation between Hamas operatives as
they're discussing the failed Islamic
Jihad rocket launch which ultimately hit
thepit
for
okay look I I I don't want to get too
lost in all of this stuff because one
way or another there is a horrific War
One play one side playing with some
rules far more rules than any other
Western Nation would play right have you
ever heard of any war going on ever in
the history of the world outside of when
it comes to Israel where they're
dropping leaflets they're asking people
to move like ship blows up in any other
country they do whatever they got to do
and nobody cares right like that's just
that's just the reality so I don't want
to get too lost in the minutia of okay
there's Hamas guys being like yeah it
was Islamic Jihad here's the video of it
it's shown on Al jazer what I what I'm
really more focused on is how
our media members whether they're Jake
Tapper or the the Hamas people over at
MSNBC Andrea Mitchell Etc or uh our
politicians Rashid T bayoc how they push
this what I would say is modern blood
liable right and then it confuses
everybody so Joe Biden is actually in
Israel right now he took the long trip
he's he's extremely tired and mumbly and
everything else here he is basically
admitting that it was not Israel who did
it was deeply sadden and outrage by the
uh explosion at the hospital in Gaza
yesterday and based on what I've seen it
appears as though it was done by the
other team not not you but there's a lot
of people out there not sure so we got a
lot we got to overcome a lot of
things like man is he instilling any
confidence right now like the United
States is being pretty decent about this
right now in that in that we're
basically saying Israel you got to do
what you got to do right and that's
pretty good but the problem is that we
have this man in charge that no one
really thinks he's in charge and he's
he's tired and exhausted and doesn't
exude any strength or anything else uh
here's by I mean watch this like tell me
does this feel like the guy that should
be in charge of of literally the world
right now as as we seem to be careening
off the
cliff you know uh years ago I asked the
Secretary of State when he and I are
working in Senate to write something for
man and he said uh you wrote a line that
uh I think is
appropriate he said uh it's not we lead
uh not just uh well I won't go into wait
later taking too much time
what what like I don't know what to say
about that right now like we've made all
sorts of jokes for the last two plus
years well even before he was president
about Joe Biden and what was going on
with him and by the way when you travel
from DC to Israel even when you're in
Air Force One and you can sleep a young
person could be jetlagged and tired
right like but this guy is not up to the
task right now and it's it's deeply
depressing if you really think about
that but anyway they spread this This
Modern Blood liel by the way Rashida
Talib and AOC uh sorry Rashida TB and
ilhan Omar have not deleted those tweets
okay so those tweets are still up and
then do you know what happened within an
hour if not within minutes of all of the
mainstream media and the Hamas caucus
and everybody else saying that Israel
bombed a hospital well then riots
started basically uh well they've been
going on everywhere but these protest
and riots uh were ignited even further
throughout the world we've got about a
minute compilation uh this is Middle
East Canada you'll see a whole bunch
more Jordan
Etc
[Music]
is
you know when you see the the Beirut
Embassy there uh 5 days from now is the
40th anniversary of the Beirut Marine
Barracks bombing so it's like where're I
think we lost 250 Marines if I'm not
mistaken look the stuff that's going on
there in the Middle East these these
governments have treated their people
horribly they have lied to them about
history and everything else they've
abused their human rights and if you
think if you think for one second that
this somehow is Israel's fault for
responding as they had burned babies and
beheaded women that it's their fault
that suddenly all this happened no these
things these things were just festering
and waiting to blow up right so it's
that's just obvious the depressing part
really though is when you see this in
Canada the depressing part is when you
see it in Australia and you see it here
on the streets of the United States of
America here is a free Palestine crowd
okay and again when they mean free
Palestine they mean kill 8 million Jews
that that's what they mean they're not
saying go back to the nth they don't
even pretend anymore five years ago they
used to pretend go back to the 1967
borders which were completely uh
artificial by the way and that wouldn't
have left you with a two-state solution
because Gaza and the West Bank are
completely separate from each other so
that would have been a three state
solution but putting that aside for just
a sec um this has nothing to do with uh
it has everything to do with basically
just killing 8 million Jews and then
moving on to the rest of the West how do
I know that well when people tell you
something you should listen so here is a
free Palestine crowd in Boston which is
a it's a pramas these are people are
pramas remember there's nobody out there
going you know guys Hamas is a bit much
we're not thrilled with the Israelis but
okay uh but yeah they're not just
chanting about uh Israel they're coming
for America too Boston Massachusetts the
United States biggest threat in the
world
today the USA so when they try to
isolate the Palestinian resistance and
vilify it what are we going to do we're
going to fight back
right so that's right outside Harvard
did he catch it there saying biggest
threat in the world today Israel and the
USA so again you don't I think it's a I
think it's a mistaken worldview but I
can accept the worldview of someone
who's a total
isolationist and who who doesn't want
foreign aid to anyone and who wants
America to have no role in the world
like I can intellectually I can accept
that I don't think that makes you a bad
person right I think maybe you're a
little mistaken in in how sort of real
politic or the real world operates um
but if you think that they're not coming
for the rest of the West next right
Israel is just the front line of this
thing and then what do you do you think
again I I'll just keep saying it until
more and more people get it they could
take out Israel take out those 8 million
Jews they're goingon to have to kill
about two million Muslims who live there
peacefully too and beduins and
everything else the only place in the
Middle East that is anything like
coexistence etc etc where minorities are
treated fair and people actually vote
for their leaders and everything but do
you think they will wrap it up and go
home after no they will just start
moving
on and again who do you think is more
indigenous to the land Israel Jews to
the ancient land of Israel or those
people uh chanting with Hamas flags and
they're Hamas Flags they're not
Palestinian Flags there is there's no
differentiation because none of them are
making the differentiation so I don't
think I have to who do you think is more
indigenous to the land like you got it
but I want to connect this to the other
thing that we've been talking about for
years or oh wait I'm G to just back up
for one second I should have shown this
before but the reason I had the New York
Times head the New York Times paper on
my uh desk here was because when we
showed you those New York Times
headlines before where they just changed
things in real time right and they're
just ly yeah here you go so remember it
was Israeli strike kills hundreds in
hospital Palestinians say then they
realize oh we're in trouble it's
not true then at least 500 that didn't
strike in Gaza hospital because then
they're still blaming Israel but not
they're backing up a little bit and then
500 dead in Blast cuz then they realize
oh it wasn't a strike it was actually
from one of their own Rockets I want to
connect this to The Wider woke thing and
how the media has lied to us of
everything so I've referenced this
before I've shown it to you once or
twice before the New York Times
Obviously has gone after me and plenty
of other decent people many times but
this was front page of the New York
Times on Sunday June 9th 2019 so over
four years ago it was called the making
of a YouTube radical and how a bunch of
people like Jordan Peterson and Milton
fredman and who else is on here there's
Phil
DeFranco and Ben Shapiro of course how a
bunch of us were leading
people on YouTube to become alt-right we
know it was completely the reverse by
the way they didn't include me in this
Montage on the front page but I did get
even a bigger picture of me in the big
spread in the Middle look at me look at
me right in the corner I was so young no
beard I was just a young bright-eyed
Optimist bright-eyed Optimist leader of
the alt-right anyway the point of this
to show you this is that these people
have been lying about everything forever
like think how actually hilarious it is
now to think that they P they with a
straight face that yes it was YouTube
leading people to the alt right YouTube
has Le been leading YouTube has been
leading these genderless purple haired
dingbats to become Hamas supporters so
you see I think you see the point so now
I want to connect this to The Wider uh
sort of woke world because uh you know
one of my favorite lines related to all
of this from years ago Douglas Murray
the great uh author and and good buddy
of my Douglas Murray British uh uh
author uh he said years ago on my show
it's the line that I I quote often he
said you know the barbarians will one
day be at the gate and we will be
debating what pronouns to call them and
that's basically where we are right now
and one of the other lines that I often
quote is from Peter beian who has said
many times that once wokeness enters an
institution it destroys the institution
right so once wokeness is in the
government they take their eye off the
pole of what the government's actually
supposed to do or the military what the
military is actually supposed to do or
the border right once they start
becoming woke they're not thinking of
they're putting energy in places that
energy should not be so now I want to
show you a video of Senator John Kennedy
who is one of our last remaining great
Senators uh from Louisiana of course and
here he is explaining now because as you
can see there's a push to somehow get
gazen refugees here it's so
bananas it's ridiculous um here he is
explaining how
wokeness has actually degraded our
ability to basically do anything right
when it comes to this
Administration I think we need to ask
ourselves though Martha why are we here
and I think we have to be honest with
ourselves um America has a pres
president who is uh who is not a defense
Hawk uh America has a president whose
administration is frankly more
interested in
discussing whether a man can breastfeed
than it is in talking about National
security yeah it's like yeah he's right
think of all the time we've wasted on
bathrooms and whether third graders
should be reading pornography and
everything else we've completely taken
our eye off the ball instead of focusing
on the basic stuff the basic stuff have
a border have Law and Order would that
be pretty good I think that would
usually be pretty good but now I want to
show you how when I talk about how
wokeness infects everything so that's
that's exactly what Kennedy is saying
there right you start thinking about or
can can guys give birth and next thing
you know you're not paying attention to
the border right well you want to see
how that connects to how the media
treats things so you remember earlier in
the week I I played a clip of the ladies
of the view and it was it was rather
shocking because four of the women at
that table were not completely insane
for one day and that was so refreshing
it was so nice but Anna Navaro is back
to her usual self and I want to connect
this to the woke thing that I'm talking
about so right now that there there are
a bunch of nominees to be in military
positions who are hung up right now uh
because they you know we go through a
process right you you are vetted they
want to find out what your thinking is
what your policies are Etc this is what
the Senate does and Senator Tommy tuber
bill from Alabama he's a republican uh
he's holding up a bunch of these
nominees Because he believes that a lot
of these people are woke that they want
to inject gender and sexuality and skin
color and all the rest of it into the
military so he's trying to find out more
about these people but look how Ana Naro
goes after him for doing what we all
know is the right thing she also makes a
joke here about a potato that makes no
sense to me but if any of you can figure
it out I would love to love to know what
it is your point about uniting against
terrorism it it occurred to me this
weekend you know we're we're sending two
aircraft carriers to the Middle East
there's going to be there's about 10,000
servicemen there and women we have
Marines and the and hor moves and we
have got a senator from Alabama and the
US Senate who is holding up over 350
appointments of Admirals and eneral and
leaders in the military Senator
tuberville it is time that you stop this
stupidity because we need our military
leaders confirmed he's so apply named
tuberville cuz he's got the common sense
of a
potato okay I didn't get the joke Whoopi
didn't get the joke I'm told that
potatoes what are you telling me now are
a
tuber a potato is a stem tuber his name
is tuberville actually so I
mispronounced it as well but a potato is
a stem tubber I I don't know what that
means but but that's the potato joke was
not the point the point was you see how
she's connecting this the guy's trying
to stop some of the woke stuff from
getting in our military I don't I don't
know anything about these 300 some odd
Admirals that that are trying to get in
but like we do know we have a problem
but you see how the Liberals they get
everything wrong right so anaro has
basically gotten everything wrong for
the last 5 years then finally she sees a
burned baby and she makes sense for one
day but then the next day it immediately
is now the Republicans are bad because
they're not giving us everything we
want but speaking of terrible people
with bad ideas vice president Cala
Harris and this woman the idea that this
woman could be president at any moment
any moment is so right now like it was a
joke for two years but now in light of
what's going on in the world it's
starting to get a little scary uh here
she is going after Ronda santis because
Ronda santis has ended all of the
diversity equity and inclusion uh
departments here in Florida whether they
were in our schools or in our government
or elsewhere he wants us to not care
about skin color he wants us to not care
about gender and we know once again The
Barbarians will be at the gate and we'll
be debating what gender pronouns to call
them once you bring these things in you
see what happens Disney starts pushing
sexual on kids and then these
things are all connected I think you
guys got it you're you're W you know
what's nice about this audience I'm not
I'm not talking to morons and I think a
lot of the time CNN knows they're
talking to morons so they have to do it
in moronic language anyway here's Kamal
Harris it is important to see what is
happening in our country right now with
some extremist leaders who are attacking
Dei diversity equity and inclusion
they're doing with that the same thing
that they have been attempting to do
with woke which is to turn it into a bad
word and turn it against those of us who
understand the true meaning you look at
what's happening in States like Florida
where there are undoing Dei diversity
equity and inclusion programs where
corporations are starting to shut down a
priority on those
issues diversity is our strength as a
country always has been gets back to the
point about
immigration Equity well what is the
importance of equity it's basic it's
this while we all want to fight for
equality everybody should get the same
amount that doesn't take into account
the fact not everybody starts out on the
same base
so if you're giving everybody the same
amount but they didn't start out on the
same base they're going to end up
behind man she's a communist she's a
communist and by the way the day before
the election the day before Joe Biden
was elected into office she put out a
cartoon video basically arguing for
Equity over equality it is it is
completely antithetical to everything
that America and capitalism is all about
she's saying everyone should end up in
the same place everyone should get the
same amount no they shouldn't no they
you can't can't have my I work hard
I produce something that's worthy you
can't have it and you think she's given
her to anybody these people are
absolute Liars she that that is the the
Communist worldview and the Socialist
worldview and the Marxist worldview is
that you rejigger everything so everyone
has the same it's an it's it's actually
anti-human because it is your duty as a
human to go out and get what's yours
it's yours to fight for your family and
for your rights and your community and
all of those things and of course what
happens in all of those societies the
problem is that's it's so counter to
humanity that you have to kill an awful
lot of people to make everyone kind of
Equitable on the bottom right so she
doesn't mean that she won't have more
and the elites won't have more she mean
she means you won't have more also the
phrase diversity is our strength no it's
just meaningless diversity is our
strength imagine you're hiring you're
hiring a group of people you got to hire
three people we here right now we're
hiring a new editor okay we're hiring
based on skills we're hiring based on
passion and work experience and all that
right I don't sit there and go well you
know we had I don't know we had how many
resumes we got about probably about 200
rums 300 rumes something like that I
didn't go boy how many could we get as
many Nazi resumés and as many Hamas
supporter rums as people that actually
have used uh what what do you edit on
these days premere that's an editing
software
apparently I don't know how any of this
works I just sit here and talk you see
um diversity is not our strength
diversity can be a nice feature of a
society that you'd have say diversity of
thought that that's not what they want
um but let's see if diversity is our
strength so let's let's go along with
these people right they think diversity
is our strength well uh we live in a
Multicultural Society here and uh We've
now allowed all sorts of people here
it's the Democrats mostly who have done
it but the Republicans are often pretty
bad on it too New York City as you know
is being completely overrun right now
and Kathy hokel who is the uh uh she is
the governor of the state of New York um
here she is in December 21 calling for
Mass migration into New York and of
course you know how they're doing with
that right now but again I want to
illustrate how it is their specific
policies they call you racist because
you don't want a terrorist living next
door or you might want a wall or a
border but they call it all in all hell
breaks loose and they still have a way
of blaming it on you so here she is in
in December of 21 as you know the Statue
of Liberty is inscribed it says give me
you're tired you're poor your huddled
young masses yearning to be free The
Wretched refu to a teaming Shore and
that statement encapsuled our values we
want people to come here despite where
they came from or despite the
circumstances that drove them to this
country into this into this state we see
say you are welcome here we are welcome
with open arms and we'll work to keep
you safe we'll not only house you but
we'll protect you so our message to the
world is send us your people send us
those who need the uh the cloak of
comfort that we can demonstrate as New
Yorkers with big hearts and Open Arms we
played a clip of her last week she is
now saying completely the reverse of
that she's saying we have to close the
border and everything else also as the
as the governor of New York she has no I
mean she has free speech so she can say
whatever she wants but what but she has
no right to say it as the governor
within her duties as the governor not
your right to tell people break the law
the United States and come across our
border and now we know New York City is
an absolute freef fall 10,000 illegals a
month because they made it a sanctuary
City and uh Eric Adams the mayor of New
York City couple weeks ago we played the
clip many times basically being like
listen people we are you're like
I don't know what you're going to do but
I can't help you I just have a suit that
fits nice what do you want me to do so
what are the results of this diversity
if diversity is our strength and we
should open the country to everybody
well here's Washington Square Park in
New York City this used to be a place
where you could get some weed if you
were into that sort of thing it's
shifted for the worse uh here it is over
the last couple
[Applause]
days
all right again you don't have to make
this about Israel you could say all
right those 8 million Jews you got to go
Holocaust too Zippity doah um do you
think any of those people care about
American values do you think they care
about Free Speech how would you feel if
you knew that you were living next door
to one of those people like that so is
diversity our strength it's such a
blanket stupid phrase no human is
illegal B why do you have a freaking
lock on your door no human is illegal
like it's all they have lied to us about
everything and by the way guys as I keep
saying the Silver Lining to everything
happening right now is there is a small
set of people waking up I'm getting a
lot of texts from people who have not
spoken to me in years who are suddenly
like you know Dave maybe you weren't
wrong about all of this stuff you never
get the apology you don't have to wait
for the apology it ain't coming but you
got to let people kind of wake up on
their own so what do we do what do we do
and by the way America is is has a
little more time on this than they have
in Europe because Europe has has been
ransacked and overrun with much of this
and it probably leads to Civil Wars and
like that's just the truth in in France
and Britain like you can sort of feel it
coming America has done a much better
job of integrating people America
doesn't have people living in little
little HS here and there that are
completely separated we have done it all
right these people are now here to undo
it and they're doing it in the name of
wokeism and they're doing it in the name
of the Democrat Party and they're doing
it now in the name of Hamas which is
just wild so what do you do you know
what you could do you could try to every
now and again find a political leader
who is telling you the truth no matter
how Politically Incorrect it is laying
it out who has a track record of doing
what he says he's going to do and you
might want to make that guy president
you're right if you if you let people
come illegally without a sanction you're
going to continue to have this problem
the sanction is you get deported so
we're going to do it we'll start with
the more recent arrivals and work our
way back uh but it's going to be a big
program uh similar to what Eisenhower
did in the 1950s and I'm really the only
candidate that you can trust to do it I
mean I know Donald Trump's promising it
but he said the same thing in 2016 and
didn't deliver on it a lot of the other
Republicans as you rightfully point out
they're uncomfortable even talking about
doing that but we're never going to
solve the problem unless we have the
rule of law Prevail look here's the
simple truth you know it's funny what do
I always say uh you don't have to be a
republican but you can't be a Democrat
we only have these two parties right now
that's just kind of how it is by the way
I I'll be interviewing RFK Jr in a
couple days and now he's an independent
but like we know he's not going to be
president of the United States and I'll
even say that to him in the interview
okay um we're doing that live in LA in a
couple days um but you don't have to be
a republican but if you can't see the
difference like I don't consider myself
a republican from first off I'm I'm like
the least traditional conservative in
the history of the world let's let's
start with that I consider myself a
Florida Republican because we're doing
it right here we are defending a culture
of Freedom so if you want that exported
to the rest of the country you want to
find somebody that can maybe fix it it's
like we do have the answer to all of
that but what is the the end result of
all of this if we if we continue to go
the way of the Democrats we will keep
letting people in we'll have no idea
what their beliefs are we will have
riots and and pramas rallies everywhere
we'll have we'll have another generation
that will gladly undo all of the
goodness of America and they will use
all of our freedoms against us or we
could actually start being serious as a
country we could say these are things we
stand for we have a culture we stand for
we have Law and Order that we stand for
we have founding documents that are
Prett pretty damn great and if you don't
like it you got to go we could do that
and then you know what we could do if we
did that we could reverse America and
reverse it in the best way possible we
could go back say I don't know how how
many years you want to go back 30 years
let's go back 30 years you know what New
York City looked like in 1993 how about
[Music]
this
he
[Music]
I like that kind of music I like
elevator music that whatever that is I I
like that kind of thing anyway I show
you that because that is not what New
York City is like now there are drug
addicts everywhere there are illegals
everywhere there are virtually no people
people uh in suits anywhere in New York
City New York City which used to Midtown
New York City was people of doing
business now it's just people in hoodies
basically either going to buy drugs or
going to sell drugs or going to stab
somebody who didn't pay them for the
drugs okay so we have watched our
society's collapse we have watched our
cities collapse and maybe we can reverse
some of it maybe but we would need to
elect serious people so I think you get
the point but it doesn't it's not just
the politicians it's actually you it's
actually you fighting for what's true
telling people what's true stop voting
for the wrong people call out the
when you see it like stop
paying for a subscript I know this is a
big one with a lot of liberals a lot of
liberals they now hate the New York
Times but they can't stop paying for it
stop paying for the New York time stop
paying for the people stop stop paying
the people who are ushering in the
people to behead you they're going to
behead you one way or another but you
shouldn't even you shouldn't be funding
the beheading uh I want to show you one
other thing because I meant to show you
this earlier uh but you know when I was
showing you that that New York Times
article and how they've changed the
headlines three times check this
out the image that they use right there
in Israel strikes hundreds in hospital
Palestinians say that image they're
showing you isn't even the hospital
that's not even the hospital okay that's
somewhere else altogether in Gaza so
they have lied about
everything we know they're lying they
know they're lying we know they know
that we know that they know that they're
lying I added a one an extra one in
there but you get the point and they
continue to lie let's do a little bit
better by the way reports are coming out
just since we've been doing the show
that it didn't even hit the rocket
actually didn't even hit the hospital
the gazin rocket shot by Islamic Jihad
it actually hit a parking lot next
door we got a postgame show coming up at
Ruben report. locals.com I will see you
there I thank you guys for watching and
we'll be back at it tomorrow
bye
[Music]